congressman adam kinzinger is one of a
growing number of house republicans to
publicly say
they will vote to impeach the president
he joins us now congressman kinzinger
thanks for being with us
you bet just a few days ago you said an
interview that you didn't think
impeachment was uh the smart move in
your words because it victimizes donald
trump
again what's changed in your thinking
well nothing's changed it's just going
to be in front of us now
and i think when it was a tactical
question it was you know look we have 12
days left is it worth it but here it is
and and i think looking at the
impeachment article
and knowing that the president incited
an insurrection
and now you know steps out and claims he
bears no responsibility
i think in my mind at least in my
conscience and what i believe
my job is there's no way i could vote no
on this you're one of five
uh republicans so far uh to have
publicly said they'll vote for
impeachment how many more
do you think there are likely to be so i
don't want to get in the guessing game
because
i don't want to guess high or guess low
i will tell you they'll be more than us
and i'm not sure you know what that
means but i think it's certainly
going to be notable because i mean look
this is a moment where you know the base
the
the republican bases they feel left
behind they feel disaffected
and right now they still believe that
donald trump is actually working on
their behalf in reality i think he's
been working against them now especially
since the election
so these are tough votes but i think
there will be more than
the five you've seen so far what do you
say to some of your fellow republicans
who are arguing that impeachment will
only further divide the country
well look i guess i understand that
point and and that's why i said look i
think that bringing it here isn't
necessarily the right move but now that
it's coming
it does what what matters is you you
make a decision to protect and defend
the constitution the question is did the
president
incite a riot against
an article one against the the congress
yes he did
and so should he be held responsible and
i said in my statement if this
is not risen to the level of impeachment
i don't know what is and the bottom line
is this you know we
we talk all the time about young people
that fight and die for this country
we do it with a tear in our eye we speak
of memorial day parades and we should do
all that
but we have to be willing to give up our
career for the same cause even if it's a
different form
i mean this is one of these moments that
transcends politics
congressman have you personally received
threats about this vote
sure yeah i mean you do you know are
they serious or not
some are some are you know put on i
guess parlor or twitter
but i won't be intimidated i'm not
trying to sound like you know mr tough
guy but
if i'm going to be intimidated i should
leave this job and let somebody who
won't be intimidated come here so i
won't be
obviously i'm a military guy so but yeah
we live in the time right now where
there are people that are willing
to take violence to members of congress
because of a political view or because
they have been brainwashed some to the
point to believe
that this is the end of their life in a
you know a democratic republic
because they've been told that
congressman kinzinger thank you very
much for being with us this morning
you bet thanks